-Here's how this
is going to work.
You and I will take turns
hitting this button here,
which will randomly select
one of these icons on the board.
Each icon will reveal
something that you must share
from your phone.
Neither of us know
what any of these will say.
We're just --
We're told to bring our phones.
-Yep.
-Okay,
and you're cool with this?
-Yeah.
-Alright, I don't know
if I'm cool with it.
-I think.
-Yeah, I know.
I'm like, "Alright."
-I didn't even clean out
my phone before.
-Me, neither. I have no idea.
But I have nothing really
to clean out.
-Yeah, I honestly --
I don't, either.
-Yeah, alright.
Alright, here we go.
Since you're my guest,
you're up first.
When you're ready,
hit that button.
-Okay.
[ Beeping ]
-Oh, okay, that's --
-Text message?
-Show us the last text
between you and your spouse.
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on. It's only
the first round.
It's only the first round.
-Wait, no one
can see my password.
-Oh, yeah, someone's gonna
figure it out.
-I'm unlike my husband where
I show my passwords when I...
-[ Laughs ] That was the best.
-...I'm on TV.
-That was the best
when he did that.
-Okay, okay. Last text message.
Last text message.
-You and Kanye.
-Okay, okay, okay, okay.
You ready? It's fine.
It's fine. It's so sweet.
Do I put it here?
-Yeah.
[ Bang, bang ]
What? No. Your phone is locked.
-Aah! Wait, sorry.
[ Audience exclaims ]
-What was that one?
-No, I got a text
and something from Kylie.
Hold -- Okay.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I don't know
what's going on. Sorry.
It popped up, and I tried
to swipe up the text
and -- Okay.
-Alright, let's see it.
Here we go. Put it there
and do not touch.
[ Bang, bang ]
Your phone is now locked!
"West Lake --
The first ranch in our family.
50 years from now,
this will mean so much to us."
[ Audience "aww"s ]
-I told you, it's sweet.
-It is sweet.
What is that? What is --
-Okay, so,
he got a ranch in Wyoming.
-[ Gasps ]
-And they're on the lake.
It has something
that's called West Lake.
So he took a picture of it,
and that's, like, a sign.
And he's so excited
to maybe be moving to Wyoming.
I don't know. I don't --
Well, not full-time.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Here we go.
Alright, this is my turn here.
-Okay, okay.
-Let me hit the button here.
[ Beeping ]
My last text from my wife,
what would that be?
-What?
-Let the other person play
any of your voice memos.
-Do you do voice memos a lot?
-I do it too much,
actually, yeah.
-Really?
-I'll wake up
at like 3:00 in the morning
and just sing a song in my phone
and think it's good.
-Yeah.
-But they're mostly bad.
But don't --
Here. But just don't --
[ Laughter ]
-You know what I do
on my voice memos?
I record, as I'm putting my kids
to bed, I press "play,"
and I listen to their stories
that they tell me for bed.
So one day -- I have them all
from my nephew Mason
when I would babysit him.
And so I hear the cutest things
that they say
that I'll play for them one day.
-That's a genius idea. That's --
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I meant to say that's what I do
with my voice memos.
Alright, well, this is --
Pick a -- Pick a voice memo.
I don't know which one it's
going to be. They're all --
-I think that --
-Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Whoa, you have so many. Okay.
I'll just play the first one.
I don't know.
-Alright.
-So I just --
-Put it on this guy. Lock it in.
-"I don't like this."
That's what it's called.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a song called
"I Don't Like This."
And it's --
-Okay, so I press that?
-Yeah. You press this, and it --
It's not ready yet,
so you just know.
It's called --
♪ No, I don't like this ♪
♪ No, no ♪
♪ Colonoscopy ♪
Colonoscopy.
[ Laughter ]
♪ See inside of me ♪
Sees inside of me.
So it's a work in progress song
about getting checked
and anyways -- Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It sounds like it's --
It sounds like it's a --
-Sounds like an old
country folk song.
-Yeah, I wish it was louder.
Sorry. Alright, let's move on.
Your turn. You hit that button.
-Oh, okay.
[ Beeping ]
-Safari.
Show us your last Google search.
Do you know how to do that?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't --
-You can't -- You can't --
-You could have warned me
so I could, like...
-You can't delete this.
-...clear search history.
-Kim, it's almost time.
Show us your phone.
-Oh, my God, you guys.
This is so embarrassing.
-Come on.
-Oh, my God. Do I have to?
-Come on. Just do it.
Just do it.
-You're not going to understand.
-No, I could --
I can figure it out.
[ Bang, bang ]
Your phone is now locked.
"Is shapewear
with pee hole better?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Foghorn blows ]
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Wait, "is shapewear
with pee hole better?"
-No, I just --
I just launched SKIMS.
And I've been debating
if I need a pee hole
in certain of the things
or if --
'Cause, like, I would --
Like, under a dress to,
like, the Emmys or whatever,
I would, like, try
to use the pee hole.
And then you pee
all over yourself,
and it doesn't -- It doesn't
work half the time anyway.
-I think you're the only person
that Googled that at all.
-No, this is
such a legit question.
So --
-Of course it's better, right?
What was the answer --
What came up?
-I mean, it's, like, mixed.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, here we go. Alright.
It's my move here.
Here we go.
Shapewear with a pee hole.
What if mine lands on "clock"?
What happens with "clock"?
What time is it?
-Ooh.
-What's your voicemail greeting
when people call you?
-Ooh.
-It's normal, I think.
It's just me going,
"I'm not here."
-I don't even have voicemail.
[ Laughter ]
That's, like, ancient.
Does anyone have a voicemail
these days?
It's just like, "Text me."
[ Audience exclaiming ]
-Are you serious?
-Yes, just text or call back.
-But what if it goes to you?
Do I hear your voice going,
"Hey, I don't do this."
-No. It's like --
[ Imitates failed call tone ]
Jimmy, show us your phone.
-Oh, yeah, here we go.
So, this is it.
Here, this is --
This is my greeting that people
hear when you call me.
[ Bang, bang ]
-Okay.
-[ Beatboxing ]
-[ Rapping ]
♪ Leave a message at the beep ♪
♪ Like an eagle grabs
with the talons ♪
♪ You're leaving a a message
for Jimmy Fallon ♪
♪ He's got various talents ♪
♪ But listen, he's got
lots of [bleep] to do ♪
♪ So please
respect the balance ♪
♪ Leave a message
at the sound of the tone ♪
♪ This is Lin Miranda
freestylin' on his phone ♪
♪ He paid a lot of money
for this, please be sweet ♪
♪ And please leave a message
at the sound of the beep ♪
-[ Imitates beep ]
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I'm very proud of that.
I don't get to hear that.
-That is very good.
-I don't get to hear that.
That's Lin-Manuel Miranda.
-Oh, no way.
-This is back
when he was doing --
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, he did --
He did "Hamilton"
over at The Public.
And I won some charity thing
for that.
Thank you, Lin.
Okay, for our final round,
our friend Winnie Harlow
is on the show.
And she heard we were
playing this game.
She wanted to get in
on the action.
She had an idea for something
that we could do.
Please welcome Winnie Harlow,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Take it easy on me.
Take it easy on us, please.
Oh, my God.
-Take it easy.
-Take it easy on us, please.
Alright, Winnie,
what do you have for us?
-Well, this last round
is for both of you.
-Okay.
A challenge?
-Are you guys ready?
-Yeah.
-Pick any photo from the other
person's deleted folder
and post it to Instagram.
[ Audience groaning ]
-Wait, from deleted?
-Yep.
So you know it's going be bad,
'cause it's in
the deleted folder.
-I feel like I'm going to have
much worse photos of my face...
[ Laughter ]
...than you will.
-Just don't scroll too much.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry.
-Alright.
-It's all good in here.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
That's not bad.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Wha-- What?
You already found one?
You look great in all of these.
♪♪
-Can I ask your opinion?
-Okay.
-Is that funny? Like,
who takes pictures like this?
-That one, or that one.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you looking at?
-I like this one.
-"Who takes pictures like this?"
-I think that's the best one.
-You look great in all of these.
But where's --
Where is this?
Where is this one?
Did you post this one?
-Oh, no, that's --
-Where are you,
in, like, a hotel or --
-No. That's in my closet.
And that's in a fitting
wearing this outfit.
So there was a hundred of those,
because I was trying on --
-That's your closet?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, your closet looks good.
-I was trying on --
Don't go zoom in.
-I zoomed in a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't go zooming in.
-Alright.
-I have, like, no make-up on.
[ Laughter ]
-But you still look gorgeous.
-Wait, I literally --
You might have a booger
in your nose in this one.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't get boogers in my nose.
That's not true.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Okay.
-I think I got yours.
I'm going to do this one of you.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
[ Bang, bang ]
Phone is locked in.
Can we see what you look like?
Like -- You look like you're --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the worst photo
I could find.
Every one was gorgeous.
-See, it's
the same outfit, though.
-That was like,
"Hurry, I hate fittings.
I think we got it."
-Alright. Well,
I'm going to post this.
-Okay. Post it to my stories.
-I think you got him, though.
-Okay. I got him beat.
Okay? He got a good photo.
-Let me see it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Bang, bang ]
-And I already --
-Is that -- That's not --
I didn't know what I was doing.
-Guys.
-I was trying to get --
There's not anything in there.
-Is that booger in there?
-You're a liar.
That is not at all.
That is actually real bad.
[ Laughter ]
It's actually awful. Alright. So
you're going to post that one.
-Should I say, like,
"I hacked Jimmy's phone.
It's me"?
-Yeah. Yes.
-Yeah, please do that.
-Okay.
Wait, you don't follow me? Oh.
-Oh, my, God. That's not --
[ Audience groaning ]
No, that is so last year!
No one follows anyone anymore.
[ Foghorn blows ]
It's, like, up there
with voicemail.
Are you kidding me?
No, of course I follow you.
-I need an extra follower,
so I'm taking that.
-My thanks to
Kim Kardashian-West.
Winnie Harlow!